thank you accountant temistocle ambrosini that excuse us if we do not enjoy as we should this high
window on New York that has cost you so much effort we must go down quickly because a
kind Italian recently married an American is waiting for us and we want to know from her how
she is in his new homeland it's hard to say how I really find myself I tend not to be very
objective when it comes to housework you see it's not just a matter of comfort or not but it's
also just a matter of real nostalgia I have such nostalgia for 'Italy and
then he knows what he wants for a shadow like me I am from Perugia for ages you know what it means not to have that
view for the panorama that a fogar every time you speak from the window Perugia you see a
wonderful view of the hills Umbria similar mountains and here unipol and look at me out of the window
of the hives of the cases harmony all the various to the other it really feels like nothing here
no you can go back I would go back immediately I abb abstance of america enough of america for me
says the italian mrs johnson from perugia who has recently married an american and who has made the
great journey from green umbria to one of these barracks in new york enough of america
we gave her the floor for objectivity because his is a reaction common to many
Italians when they come into contact with the most advanced industrial civilization of
our time for objectivity because now we are instead introducing you to other
Italians to whom this civilization is not only not alien but is connatural work of their
work part of their Italian lives that is that america are building
these skilled workers oxidized carpenters re painters blacksmiths masons who work
hundreds of meters from the ground without dizziness right in the heart of manhattan and this beautiful
girl who in the american fashion raises the flag on the day of roof covering are at the top
is at the base of the biggest skyscraper in new york the american flags na is English because
Americans and English were capitals to build the colossus but Italian and the
majority of the workers are Italian and one of the architects this is the day of
the inauguration there is the governor the mayor to cut in place there is the cardinal stars and there are all the
most representative people of new york only one of the two designers is missing and to find him we went 400
kilometers from new york to boston in fairfield street in a quiet quiet neighborhood
here we could finally see the dean of the faculty of architecture of the mighty one
of the most famous polytechnics in the world the american architect of italian origin pietro belluschi
you have to excuse me if i don't speak italian too clearly i have been in america for 40 years and there
are many and i have not had the opportunity to speak my native language much often they asked me
to talk about two projects in which I have been I am or not they asked me to be a consultant
one is the pan american and the other or list without here it is one of the two projects the new colossus
of manhattan right in the center of the island not as high as the empire state but more capacious
to build it without hindering traffic a fleet of squares was used to
transport the river that it runs along the east side of manhattan
the material then started through the road at the base of the skyscraper
but this base is not made up of common foundations but from the grand central the
busiest railway station in new york look at the tracks are underground on two
levels one above and the else under it is fine the foundations descend between the shelters and
are hooked to the ground with shock absorbers to prevent the vibrations of the trains from
propagating to the colossus perhaps you will not believe but even one day the railway traffic
stopped while the giant was fixed on the rock by two levels underground 30 thousand
people go up every day with escalators to the first floor and from here with 70 censors to their
offices there an elevator is reserved for the New York post office which reaches the airports
from the roof by helicopter in a few minutes and was rarely one of the most and most interesting projects in
which my life has person and even one of the most difficult of course it is difficult to build a
skyscraper on the railways but many years before berlusca arrived in america building the
same railways was not easy and it was Italian emigrants in the great majority who did it
and if they called each other and sabers not because they carried the saber but for the
English name of the spade which is precisely stamped and pushing this saber came out of New York
that spread everywhere because every now and then they left the railway and put on a country
and from here violent to the number of names of Italian cities in the image gradually arrive
a in california and from bricklayers carpenters and sabers returned to being those who
were in the majority when peasants left Italy and here they put the roots of qu she who
was to become the great californian agriculture of course first they planted vineyards i
am not luigi father the third generation of my family was present here in the united states in 1886
my grandfather raffaello pieces came here in san francisco from a small dinner town
out of luca calling picciorana when he first arrived here in san francisco he started
working in a small winery after 23 years working in this winery he bought a
knife and a bottle factory chin of wines the family worked everything together and
they done well enough in the wine lighthouse misters and the hostel that of when in 1983
the vision and reflection test ended here in the united states my family hariri entered
the wine phase at the beginning we went up in the nappa valley and we bought a
winery of about a million liters capacity from that little beginning now we have
about 300 million l events itri of capacity to transport all this wine in fact all the
facts the united states we have built a ship this ship is very large having a capacity
of about 10 million liters of capacity our ambition in everything is to teach
people hoping that they drink more or less and less milk that nowadays they drink a lot here
in the united states we do not know if from his office in san francisco, mister luigi m of course the
greatest winemaker in the world with a glass designed on the fate of the company will be able to
convince the americans to abandoning milk and giving oneself to wine, however, it must be said that in San Francisco
the offensive is in full development because there are so many Italian restaurants that not
looking at jungle a little closed by the golden gate you can believe you are in Naples or on the Ligurian Riviera
and in the small harbor of the fishermen almost a small living room of san francisco they
go to chat the brands are named orlando leonilda anita sant'antonio
i citizens of italian origin are now almost a third of the population of san francisco but
60 years ago at the time of the earthquake they were only a fifth of course as everyone will pour
everything into that mess that reduced ashes desolation the american pearl of the pacific
the gas pipes were gone shattered at the first tremors that on the morning of April 18, 1906
had reduced the houses to rubble the firefighters could not members the gas carried the fire everywhere
people were camped waiting for the end of that mayhem many flocked to the
town hall to hear from relatives and some friends who then disappeared in front of the fire and the smoke
that pressed more packed up and left san francisco among these there were caruso who was
singing at the opera is a young man named amedeo giannini who had recently founded a small
bank for our emigrants among so many destroyed carriages giannini managed to find one in
good condition and two horses loaded the bank money and he brought it to safety in san matteo near
san francisco when the fire went back to the city and set up shop at the port by lending money
on trust without guarantee to those who were rebuilding the city they put the trams back in what the
first cars went and died the bank di giannini was called benko vitali bank of italy
and had been founded two years before the fire after giannini continued with the scandal of
traditional bankers to lend to people rather than large companies and often without coverage
he understood that the spring of america it was trust in others as well as in the future
the atari found the right way would be so much that after the war as one of the current
ten presidents of the william muriale bank says shortly after the first world war mr giannini
hearing the apartments for his parents' land went to Italy and establish an affiliated bank
in Italy the bank with the expansion it had during this period was no
longer a local bank for emigrants but a bank with a rather extensive purpose and therefore in
30 the bank of Italy changes its name and becomes the bank of america giannini again revolutionizes
credit by starting large-scale loans for the purchase of cars every family a
car is the slogan of the roaring twenties but cars are not enough if the cinema then found
its destination in california in hollywood and also because giannini from san francisco continues
to see far away and his bank of america willingly opens the stock exchange to finance the
new art that is becoming at the beginning of the 30s a new big industry
in 1949 and of giannini died however we saw this small bank founded in 1904
as a bank for Italian emigrants a san francesco to become the largest bank in the
world thousands and thousands of kilometers south of san francisco on the waters of the gulf of
mexico that bathes the louisiana a helicopter takes you on a ship that has written everywhere
even on the sun gives a name of Piedmontese origin, said you do not see sailors but only workers in the
method and the ship is stopped because it is fishing for oil is one of the five floating bridges
that belong to an Italian emigrant who arrived in America many and many years ago from
fubine in the province of alexandria not far from this sea in texas the wells are now a
forest and the few remaining trees seem artificial extraneous to the landscape but a little
over thirty years ago when the rush for black gold begins here too this land was almost
uninhabited one of the first to be he noticed that there was oil underneath it was precisely jones vespa
this well here has a capacity now of more than 5 500 barrels a day but since
the production in queen is regulated by the state by the rai rock commission that charged
to oil production nor to the state of tex you can only produce 20 barrels per day
and / or only for eight days a month, that is to say 160 barrels of oil per month, not necessarily
special lament for wells that can produce produce many times these quantities in a day
but look and luck is that it must be had when there is too much oil in the tex stadium and
if we leave the oil mister throws and texas and we want washington that you see yourself with its
monuments the large parks and the placid flow of the potomac river we can find some other
children of our emigrants who made a politician climbed the steps of that
united states parliament the congress is seen from above it seems with its high dome a basilica
that is the capitol elia or left is our chamber and the senate in which right is our chamber
of representatives which is almost comma i chamber of deputies in italy i am one of the representatives
named dario and billionaire of italian origin the my family comes to abruzzo and now
i have relatives who are in abruzzo in a small town called open a and also the faces of my walls
are in rome i am a representative como said of the state of connecticut which is a state in the
atlantic a state where there are many italians almost 25 percent of our personnel are Italians who
are mixed with them who came from europe irish french german in two lands and all
are there and all together in pennsylvania on the other hand in the mountains ii is a small city where
italy did not mix with others but built it by themselves after making
money as a miner this is the slate quarry that I started working 55 years ago
and all the emigrants from rose garden said today in Italy we made our first pains
then the provisional of these races were all English after the contract year the Italians and all
the Italians with the gain they made in these blackboard cables we formed the
rose garden pennsylvania and here is the country founded by Italians from Puglia trentin america 80 70 60
years ago from hunger the first to arrive had the same name as the former senator who gave us side now
some arrived in 1884 with the family and immediately called the villagers the mines gave work and
soon the world was nostalgic brought back to give the name of new italy new italy to their
first groups of houses then in 1912 they called the town rose garden from the name of what they had not
been able to do in Italy and that here instead they were building so beautiful neat and tidy
that they are proud Italian names as in one of our countries they cover the plaque to the monument dedicated to the
citizens of rose garden who died in war for their homeland america this is the shop of the shoemaker's shoe repair
expert to put it briefly with mister leonardo castellucci
i am the rosette shoemaker i think of mine i raised a dead family of
12 daughters i sent her all school to elementary school and the school is high and
this is the hall of the city council gathered to hear the report of the mayor who now
wants to say a few words to the fellow villagers who remained there for u n competition of m sports this does not ignore
the roses had appeared linea america and it is royal with him to see italy at this in which you can
see us then there milan was in como dark wanted to see all the directors of the company jan ozer
appeared venia mark and so on is the people present with you know well that scanu denio derni yes no
jones
the rome from almost all the looks Mr. president recalled by our citizens
have all been completed council thursday even in our state they are all clean i
domenico martino i am one of the oldest of farini from the rose garden countries and I can tell you that
after the effort of our fathers we can boast that we have more professionals in the
state of pennsylvania than all when the population is me then the Arab star of this
country for 40 years we have been touring Italy in montelepre but for favor 13 it's more here in rose garden america
we also have the girls learning dance now i present the teacher them the miss
now
then
and these are no longer the girls of the body of paolo di roseto pennsylvania but the girls
the boys some of italian origin came down to do it really close to miami
in florida from all the universities in the united states for the holidays
but the year the tourist and it would be difficult to distinguish the lineages even if someone
of their strength do not give family members like this student who is called elizabeth
okay they
are the grandchildren and great-grandchildren of those who so many years ta loads of products
of game circles without culture without knowing the new language that they had to
speak full of fear and hopes came from Italy after a great
white hot river of pain and love that poured on the new America homeland